simplifica la razón de latas de refresco
contra personas y nos dan este numerito
de acá que básicamente quiere decir que
por cada 92 latas de refresco hay 28
personas bueno queremos simplificar la
razón lo cual básicamente es simplificar
la fracción 92 entre 28 para hacer eso
vamos a encontrar el número más grande
que divida a 92 ya 28 y vamos a dividir
esos números entre es el número grande
va bueno para encontrar este máximo
común divisor lo que vamos a hacer es
factorizar en primos cada uno de estos
dos números entonces tenemos que 92 92
lo podemos dividir entre 2 y nos queda
46 luego 46 lo podemos dividir entre 2 y
nos queda 23 y ya tenemos 23 y ya
tenemos que 2 y 23 son números primos
entonces 92 es igual a 2 por 2 por 23
entonces no 92 latas de refresco es lo
mismo que 2 por 2 por 23 latas de
refresco
estás de refresco
fresco ahora vamos con el denominador
aquí tenemos 28 y 28 28 lo podemos
dividir entre 2 de este lado nos queda
14 14 lo podemos dividir entre 2 acá nos
queda 7 y 7 y 2 ya son primos entonces
nos queda que 28 personas son 2 por 2
por 7 por 7 personas personas y con esta
descomposición en primos ya podemos ver
que el máximo número que divide al
numerador y al denominador es 2 por 2 o
sea 4 vamos a cancelar 4 en el numerador
y el denominador aquí hay un 4 lo
cancelamos aquí hay otro 4 y lo
cancelamos y por lo tanto la razón nos
queda 23 bueno lo voy a poner así 23
latas de refresco por cada 7 personas o
bien 7 personas por cada 23 latas de
refresco eso guarde exactamente la misma
información entonces con esto ya
logramos simplificar la razón de latas
de refresco contra personas vale y en
realidad pues esto de aquí que nos dice
no sea
puedes decir a lo mejor cuantas latas de
refresco consumen siete personas en
cierta cantidad de tiempo o bueno
simplemente lo podemos pensar como una
proporción vale bueno le vamos a dejar
hasta aquí espero que te haya gustado
este vídeo